now we go to Germany where police are
still searching for a motive after a
gunman stormed a Jehovah's Witness
Meeting Hall and killed six people it
happened in Hamburg the country's second
largest city German Chancellor Olaf
scholz who is a former mayor of the city
called the attack a brutal act of
violence Chris livesay is there with the
latest
good morning we're here outside the
Jehovah's Witnesses Kingdom Hall the
scene of the shooting an extremely rare
event in a country where gun laws are
strict but according to the German
government they're not strict enough
up gunned down as they worshiped
captured on cell phone footage
Police Special Forces Storm the House of
worship finding the gunman dead believed
to have turned the weapon on himself
there must have been at least 25 shots
as the witness who filled the attack
after the police arrived there were no
shots for about five minutes then there
was another shot what started as a Bible
study ended in a bloodbath one pregnant
woman survived but the baby she was
expecting did not killed by someone the
congregation once considered a brother
police say the suspect was a former
member but his faith turned into hatred
for the very people he once prayed with
he's been identified only as Philip F in
accordance with German privacy laws also
in accordance with German law the
shooter's semi-automatic handgun
officials say he was licensed to own it
last month police say they visited the
35 year old after receiving an anonymous
tip that he was dangerously on unstable
however they could not determine mental
illness and left him only with a warning
for improperly storing ammunition
guns must be banned local resident
tsarnitz tells us you don't write love
letters with pistols just look at
America
you can hear Germans are calling for
Action the German interior Minister was
here on the scene and is now calling for
even stricter gun laws she says a draft
bill is currently in the works that
would make a medical certificate a
requirement to have a license to carry a
gun for CBS Saturday morning Chris
livesay Hamburg